seeing him get choked up over that is
getting you choked up yeah because I
know what I put him through during my
drinking first sit-down interview for
Randall MA thanks for having me this is
big time
are you scared petrified yeah cuz look
up next to my significant other who I
known as the fiancee soon-to-be wife I
think the clock is counting down I know
it's very stressful
alright before we get into that let's
rewind why we're here there's a podcast
give them Lala with Randall yes wait so
was was the Chanel bag and I'm sorry /
happy Valentine's Day we had been
wanting people to see what we are like
together for a minute and what better
way than to just have our voices and
just the banter we have back and forth
plus we're breaking him in slowly he'll
make his first appearance on Vanderpump
rules this season it hasn't happened yet
but I'm like well you'll find your
footing by like just being out there
with the podcast for now it's basically
a full manipulation what's going on yeah
no but but you know I also like the the
platform of just being able to talk you
know I don't think I'll ever be
comfortable in front of the camera and
also loll I think wanted an another
platform for her to be able to kind of
use I want all the platforms in the
world and I want them all to be named
give them you've got a little uh Veruca
Salt in you
[Laughter]
so this is our first kind of taste of
what Lala and Randall the couple is like
because for years
you are just my man we didn't even know
you had a name or a face I love it and
I'm sorry I'm not gonna put my
relationship on the forefront who are
you are you dating someone I am you are
yeah
is it the same person that you were
dating last summer that these ladies had
all heard about I'm not answering that
question
I was thrilled when I no longer had to
say my man because people start making
fun of me for it so I was like you got
to take it up with my man cuz he's the
one that chooses to be nameless and
faceless what it all fairness to me you
gotta remember I you know I've worked
behind the scenes for a long time and
when I started dating long I just
thought okay I'm dating because I fell
in love with her and I didn't think that
anybody cared about right so as that as
it became this thing it was worse that I
was trying to tell him that right she
did tell me that four out of credits her
she did say you're making it worse hun
that they they're there and I was like
no I just want to be left alone and then
after like a couple years it just got to
be so crazy that finally she took me out
of the darkness but I think that this as
soon as people starting to see kind of a
side of me I think it calmed down a
little bit and I think coming down a lot
I should have done it a long time ago
probably yeah what was the moment where
it all shifted where you said fine I
will film for the show because we got to
the point where you could say your name
and you'd step out publicly together but
you weren't filming the show I begged
him first of all I was like please like
people have to see that our relationship
is real life it just got to like I think
a point where the things that were being
said about me weren't that nice and
about our relationship weren't that nice
the way things were coming across and I
just think we were like okay you know
let's try it out on a like a dabble like
a little dabble but can I tell you
something from the last few days Jax
than hitting me a lot you were Jax text
more than like me and my mom talked okay
but you know what it is he's closest to
my age and we have a lot of fun and we
laugh together
just think what someone says about their
girlfriend we have a lot of fun yeah how
much Randall are we getting
I think they'll seem I think you'll see
more Randall than you really expected to
see I really hope that's not the case
but um but okay I feel like they're
gonna use every piece of footage but I
do think it will help to kind of set the
record straight of what this is which if
you listen to the podcast you can
understand what it is that it's a
legitimate relationship 48 I'm 29 I
still need bound chicken Y along time
I'm wearing lingerie oh my god you guys
are in love it's a real deal and it's
not like there's this misconception it's
like a sugar daddy situation I wish I
was chic enough to have a sugar daddy
I'm totally not you know that means you
got to be like glammed up all the time I
go to bed with this man in flannels and
huge furry song home and Leslie I I go
to bed with Vicks
all over my body every night and he is
repulsed by like honestly it's like
morning Vicks it's like it's like she's
a walking Vick stick and it's like cool
and I'm like but I love her and I love
her you couldn't do that with your sugar
daddy no relationship people all were
getting married yeah what I thought was
interesting that I learned from the
podcast is you are a fan of venipuncture
part of the world of Vanderpump rules
it's going so well weird is it to kind
of live in this world now here's the
truth a lot of my peers in the movie
business
Emma Martin Scorsese's partner and I
were like we were all loved the show
sees it one through four I mean it was
the biggest show ever and it was the
greatest I mean who didn't love this
show then I fell in love with somebody
from the show they only had air one or
two episodes when she come on so I was
like didn't really know she was gonna
end up being Lala
right the thing so but um so now I don't
really
watch show because they were mean to me
for many years so but I support her and
and and I okay well the shows up when
it's airing it's on in the house okay so
it's hard to yeah it's hard to avoid
even when she's not watching and we're
sitting at the house and I get home and
I get that it's the night it's airing
it's right on the TV and I'm like babe
we know we're watching the whole episode
so there are a lot of things are you
ready to watch your episode I'm
petrified of course he's ready he's like
babe it's my episode coming up they said
about they said it would be about maybe
like eight or nine weeks and okay I am
interested to see how this plays out and
petrified at the same time but anyway I
I am a I I was a am a fan and always
have been and it's surreal now because a
lot of them become my friends and are in
my wedding party
so Oh Jax and his groomsmen party and
then I have Katie Stassi and Britt it's
very it's very surreal that part but it
will be different from other Vanderpump
rules related weddings because you guys
are not gonna put it on the show that
we're still sitting there disappointing
for me but I understand why you want to
do that because it's a big day in your
life it is I you know we talked about it
and you know when I proposed to her it
was just for us and it was like the best
day ever and I it was free of judgment
people couldn't watch it and nitpick it
which but they'll be obviously there'll
be Graham and pictures and all that's
not right but is everyone from your cast
invited yeah everyone from the cast is
invited I haven't invited any of the
newbies okay but really you should who I
don't not getting involved I'm just
giving you your getting involved we have
friends
okay you know at least maybe maybe maybe
I don't know
so James gets an invite James got an
invite a year ago I would not have
predicted that James would get an invite
me neither
I know what that's like to be drunk and
do things that are totally out of
character so when I heard that he wanted
to explore not drinking for me it was a
clean sleep because I know every time
he's done anything that has been messed
up he's been drunk so I have a soft spot
for anyone who acts out when they're
under the influence and then decides to
better their life fight fixing the
problem what I found so interesting in
you sharing your sobriety journey is
there's been this weird undercurrent is
like whisper conversation of like well
will she be still like the Lala we know
will she still deliver the moments like
what do you think of that conversation
because so far you're still the Lala we
know you're still delivering the moments
I wish I quicker
I think definitely quicker and I go home
and I don't regret anything that I've
said which is the best part before your
shot for all this before you like drink
and you wake up and you're like oh I
wish I wouldn't have said that if I was
sober now I wake up and I'm like I said
that and I meant it feel good yeah but I
was worried about that too however you
know Edward and I remember you did say
to me you said well I don't even know if
I'm gonna be interesting when I said
Lala you are interesting every minute of
the day you don't need any alcohol to be
interesting Tritan and she's I mean now
she's as she's as witty as it gets but
you're right you don't have you're over
a year at this point I'm a year in four
months
wow this is I was there in her one year
she went to a meeting and stood up and
ran the meeting I did I ran my first
meeting for my one here that's amazing
it was so fun it's the little things
that make me really excited these days
getting to watch her do that one
that mean to you they just it was it was
the most beautiful moment I've had with
her I think it beats everything I mean I
think the engagement is the highest
level but her running a meeting and
talking about her sobriety and all the
things that [ __ ] over comas it was
awesome seeing him get choked up over
that is getting you choked up yeah
because I know what I put him through
during my drinking and I wrote just
remember like going into his office the
morning that I woke up and said I'm not
living this way anymore
and telling him I'm an alcoholic I need
you to support me in this because I'm
reaching out and getting help for the
first time ever like I looked at him I
felt hopeful I felt like like the
thought of that it's up to me to never
feel the way I've been feeling again I
felt empowered and like I saw light
finally I hadn't felt that in a really
long time saying that sentence out loud
I'm an alcoholic the first time you said
it you take me back to like that
something I would imagine that's one of
those things where you say it in your
head you say it in your head you've
saved in the head and you like the
moment you're like okay I'm gonna try
and say it out loud and see what it
feels like and you never did she never
did until that day she said I might of
October 22nd
I opened my eyes and said to myself
[ __ ] you're an alcoholic
and the second that I even thought I had
ever even thought that to myself it felt
like a ton of bricks had just been
lifted off of my chest it was by far the
best feeling I've ever felt in my entire
life I don't think people realized that
you were drinking all day yeah it wasn't
like you were going out and binging and
having a night it was you've had an
alcohol dependency right and I was on to
her Lane but I didn't know in the
morning she was medicating all day the
cycle never ended and she came clean
after yeah and when that felt so good
being like when he would say what about
that time I was drunk yes I was drunk
time even though I told you I wasn't I
was drinking then and Lisa Vanderpump
said to me I had no idea that you were
drinking like this I was like Lisa I've
never filmed with you sober not once
Wow so it's in a way probably this year
a lot of people got to meet you for the
first time that's how I feel I'm and I
think that's why I'm so into watching
this season because I'm also interested
in this in getting to know me because
for so long I look in the mirror and I'm
like who even are you like what do you
what do you stand for what are your
goals in life and today a year in four
months sober I can be like this is what
I stand for this is what I believe and I
can tell you what I did yesterday that
feels so good
I'm now moving to happy tears let's talk
about some happier things yeah I just
sat down with Jackson Britney Britney
said that there's a little bit of a
pregnancy pact between you her Katie and
Stassi but you all want to have kids
around the same age we're crazy yeah
that's very true because all of us have
families that live somewhere different
so to us it's like if we have babies
together then it'll be like cousins and
they'll all be in the same age group and
we can celebrate birthdays together so I
know it sounds corny and like a Lifetime
movie but
who knows if it'll work out that way
because this one over here is always
like we can wait a couple years you're
young I'm like you're not I'm gonna pop
him well you have the at least Brittany
and JAXA stylin
seems to be to get pregnant sometime in
the next 12 months yes I would I think
will I think will be solid as long as we
each have kids within a year or two of
each other keep it rolling someone has
it this year it doesn't have to be hit
the date I think they all like romantic
it's like a great but I think I think we
said like after Suzy after we get
married I think I well I suggest I'd
like to have at least a year
I'm just being perfect you know last
week he said two years okay have you
guys had conversations of how many kids
you would like to add to this family
yeah one I say two because I keep
thinking about when we have Christmas
tale when we have Christmas okay I can
picture it we have my step babies and
his girls and then they get to go off to
their mom's house together and then our
kids just like this sucks it's just me
and my mom is dad I'm thinking like and
I'm thinking like hold on the two step
babies go to private school and the one
other baby that goes to private school
this is a win we get go on a great
vacation but then if you have two and
two then we get to sit home all the
holidays no oh don't worry baby cuz it's
- whether you like it or not what do the
girls think of getting some siblings in
the mix they're excited they talk about
they wanna have a six year old grabbing
my stone one day she was like a baby
goes in down and that was like yeah and
I was like you want to be a you'll be
the older sister if Lila has a baby
that's her big thing she wants to meet
she's older sister to her little doll
babies that she's got like 18 kids so
she's like I'm ready standing up tall
all day and I was like why are you
saying like that do you go potty and she
was like this is how you stand when you
a big sister I was like
that is so cute I'm very very lucky that
that Lala and and the girls are like
besties and they hang out all the time
and they're they really are very close
and it's it's um I spent Valentine's Day
the first part of the day is I took our
10 year old to go shopping we had a
girls lunch and yeah that girls day
consisted of going to target and getting
her mom Valentine's Day card and get and
then she wouldn't drop them off at her
mom's yeah I love that you are in that
place now cuz I know things were not
there when this whole thing started
listen very cool because you guys are
like taking pictures together and post
it together it's awesome to see this I
like it it's so good
I give them both her and and their mom a
lot of credit for putting you know the
kids you know first is that what pushed
things forward is like there were a lot
of bumps in the road and then I just
think that there was one text message
that really resonated with their mom and
that's when everything just now I can't
even imagine going back to the place
that we were in at one point you know
now they talk to each other like now I
shall be like oh you know she called and
I'm gonna pick the girl's up at school
but I'm like what like aunt like now I
got outside on the outside or not before
I like to go I want to dig into
something the PJ can we get do you own
the jet I have owned different jets and
now and then we charter so it goes back
and forth
it really depends on where the company
is that you know we make a lot of films
so it just depends on does the financial
weight cuz that you know it's
inexpensive well I imagine this last
year was pretty good
[Laughter]
we work hard we work oh that's amazing I
know right Oscar nominated producer with
Martin Scorsese all four Irishman
freakin crazy it was a it was a it was a
special year and and and now like even
to my kids I just feel like their dad
can always say that they have an Oscar
nominated and Golden Globe nominee and
what is Martin Scorsese's review of love
loves love's okay yeah love I mean he he
actually uh he you met him on Irishman
set for the first time yeah he told me
he was like Emma his his good friend and
Marty's a producing partner it's like
our show me or show a couple episodes I
really enjoyed it I enjoyed it no no you
know Emma who is who is my I've made a
bunch of movies with has always been a
huge fan of known laws since that like
the first week we met and as always
thought that you know we would we would
first night ran and I hooked up is when
I met her okay we already did that whole
interview where she told me the whole
story
alright where you looking at the podcast
well y'all be talking about I'm sure
more stuff like that so you can check
your life do you have a dream guest you
love to bring on I would love to have
like Eminem or jay-z who would you say
that you would want who's like your
dream
maybe Clinton or Obama and just open up
these are some like 60 minutes level
final question for you yeah people would
like to see you transition to real
housewives at some point would you ever
be open to that or want to do that I
would love to be on Real Housewives I
think that that's an amazing franchise
and it focuses on their lives and what
they're doing in all of their lives and
I I like that I would love a show to be
like oh you'll have a beauty line that's
very successful let's talk about it that
sounds fun to me so call me you know
where to find me
yeah the exact same producer you know
where to find me call your boss yeah
there we go thank you guys that's great
that's fine
[Music]